(suspenseful music)
- So, the video was posted by a profile
called uonlywish500,
and he had made a comment that said,
"All haters can suck my huge dick LOL."
And it was a very
interesting comment to make.
I don't know why you would tell people
to do that to you.
And when I clicked on the profile,
I noticed that they had also liked a video
for the movie Catch Me If You Can.
- You're gonna get caught.
It's like Vegas, the house always wins.
(suspenseful music)
- Leonardo DiCaprio plays
a counterfeit con man,
and an FBI agent goes around trying
to track him down across the country
to catch him.
Which, to me, I took as
a big "Hey, hey, you're
never gonna catch me, haha, fuck you."
That was a message he was sending.
I'm throwing down a gauntlet.
I dare you, I challenge you to try
and find out who I am.
I was like, oh okay, this person wants
to play a game of cat and mouse.
And I'm up for that.
- You can't find a person,
but you can find objects in the room
that would tell you where this person is.
(kittens meowing)
- It looks like a very
small, cramped room.
I mean, you're talking like maybe
eight feet by ten feet wide.
But, for me, there's a
lot of information here.
You see a door, a bed,
a table.
You see a door handle,
a light socket, electrical receptacles.
(mouse clicking)
- And those are things that we know can
point to, like, maybe a specific area
of the world.
Wall sockets in England are different
than they are in California.
(notification dinging)
- We picked apart every
little thing in that room.
(mouse clicking)
Then, I created a schematic, or diagram,
of the layout of the room,
so everybody understood
where each thing was.
- The wolf bedspread.
This wolf bedspread was hideous!
And it was sold on Ebay, made by a company
in North America.
It only had one buyer,
and you couldn't see who that buyer was.
(mouse clicking)
But, it shipped internationally.
(suspenseful music)
Didn't help us at all.
He could've been anywhere on the planet.
(notification dings)
But then, holy shit, that's
a yellow vacuum cleaner.
First thing, yellow vacuum.
Okay, there's tons of 'em.
(suspenseful music)
(keyboard clicks)
One thing that I learned in all of this
is that there is an internet
forum for everything out there.
Are you into vacuums?
There's gonna be an internet forum for it.
(mouse clicking)
So, I found this vacuum
cleaner repair forum.
Thousands of people post,
"I've got this tube, I'll send it to ya".
You know, "I've got this
hose, I can send it to ya".
So, I posted to this vacuum forum.
Hey guys.
(keyboard clicking)
(suspenseful music)
They identified it immediately.
The Kenmore Canister Cleaner,
the Aspiradora model,
72126082.
Awesome, guys, thank you so much,
you've been so great to me.
I can't appreciate enough.
"Oh, you're welcome sweetheart, hey,
and just so you know,
that's only sold in North America".
So, this is it.
(computer dings)
So, whoever made this fucking video,
whoever this guy was,
we knew that we could start looking
in Mexico, the United States, or Canada.
But, they still didn't know where he was.
We went through every
picture that we could.
(computer dings)
So, sometimes, when you take a picture
there's digital information
stored in the picture,
and it's called EXIF data.
Now, the model of the
camera that took the photo,
the date the photo was taken,
the GPS location of the photo.
- You can take a photo
and upload it to a website
that will show you all the EXIF data.
So, that's exactly what we did.
(mouse clicking)
(negative beeping)
(positive beeping)
- And then, boom, it's
got GPS coordinates on it.
And it was me this time.
And I'm like holy shit.
I took a screenshot of
it, sent it to John Green.
The photo in question has Luca sitting
on a beautiful chaise lounge.
It looks to be a fancy department store.
- And, automatically, on
the EXIF site it gives
you a map and it puts a pinpoint.
(mouse clicking)
And it took me to the Toronto
Eaton Shopping Center.
Toronto, Canada.
- But, the date the picture was taken
was absolutely key.
October 25, 2010.
So at the end of October
25th, he's in Toronto,
and then the kitten killer
video happens in November.
So, we were like freaking out.
Oh my god, he's in Toronto.
We thought he might be in Canada,
but now we fucking know he's there.
He's there, he's there, he's there.
- So, I do what I do best.
I'm gonna find his actual address.
(computer dings)
I found a picture of
Luca and he's standing
on a balcony.
It's like the third or fourth floor
of like an apartment or condo.
But, what I really noticed was that
the corner of the intersection
was a gas station.
And the gas station was
called Petro-Canada.
So, the first thing I do,
is I jump on Google maps.
(John typing)
And literally there's hundreds
of Petro-Canada gas stations.
(mouse clicking)
But, I start cross referencing things.
I remember, Luca made this blog post
talking about how the
paparazzi was harassing him.
They were trying to take his
picture outside his condo
in Etobicoke, Canada.
Etobicoke?
Hmm, that's interesting.
Where is that?
Etobicoke is a suburb outside of Toronto.
I wonder how many Petro-Canadas
there are in Etobicoke?
Six.
Well, this is gonna be easy.
(suspenseful music)
(mouse clicking)
So, I literally start clicking
on each of the six
Petro-Canada gas stations.
When I click on it, I
go to the street view.
And I look at it and I
go, nope that's not it.
Number two, street view,
nope that's not it.
Number three, click.
(suspenseful music)
Oh, that looks exactly like
the Petro-Canada gas station
that I see in the photo of Luca.
And guess what?
That large, grey, cement
apartment building
is directly behind it.
So then I take my cursor, I click on it,
and I rotate the street view 180 degrees.
And I'm looking directly at the apartment
that Luca is seen in, in the photo.
304 Mill Street.
So, now
I've got this fucker.